hi christina how you doing
i am doing very well i appreciate you
talking to me
i absolutely love this show i'm one of
those people who
was not a sports fan so i was dragged
into the show kicking and screaming and
absolutely fell in love with it and
can't get enough
so thank you for converting me excellent
you're welcome
i'm curious i mean everyone calls ted
lasso a surprise hit
but was that really a surprise to you i
mean deep
in your heart did you always feel like
the show had potential to be a hit or
were you worried that it wouldn't
connect with anyone
i guess we all thought it had potential
to be a
little bit of a hit but you know we just
thought
it you had to believe in the show to
some degree and we did
um but you know there's some shows that
all of us have liked that
never quite found an audience um
and some of them you know live on you
know through streaming or whatever and
are still adored but you just don't know
where we're gonna land
and so to get the response we've gotten
is it's jaw dropping you know um
we're just we're just trying to make a a
comedy and yet people are finding
not only laughter in it but you know
you know meaning apparently meaning
um and yeah it's
it's not it's not what we were going for
it's not what we expected and it's uh
we're just very grateful it's one of
those shows that anybody i know that
tells me they're having a bad day or a
bad week i tell them have you watched
ted lasso yet because you should do that
and then they always thank me so
at least it's you know serving its
purpose
oh good that that's great please keep
describing that doctor
does the optimism of this show rub off
on any
cynicism you might have in your own life
i mean a little bit to a degree um
you know a big part of of of why ted
lasso exists is because
um three of the creators me and jason
and joe kelly
uh lived in amsterdam for a while and
though ted is you know has what i'd call
midwestern optimism
there's also a bit of dutch life
philosophy
in this as well the dutch have a concept
that uh i love
called uh uh you know things can be
schizelec
um and like i come from chicago
you know child of uh of irish catholic
uh parents who
you know uh were able to wield guilt
like a like a ginsu knife
um and then i go to amsterdam and i find
out about this thing called
and has no literal english translation
um it can be just like a warm sweater oh
gosh it felt so good i was cozzella and
i was sitting by the fire and it was
really
zealous but it can also be um
oh my god we were all hanging out and
the light it was a hot it was a you know
it was
the car broke down but but we're all in
on the side of the road but we all just
got to chatting and it ended up being
very
zelic um and bring it back to ted i
promise i will
um also means that if you
if you're worried about a thing but you
cannot affect
the likelihood of that thing to happen
or not by worrying about it
then you're wasting your time by
worrying about it it does you it does
you no good
um and again having been raised on guilt
like it was
you know wheat uh that was an incredibly
powerful concept
and i do think a big part of that is in
ted too like it's just
it just doesn't help you to worry about
that thing that thing's gonna happen or
it isn't
so uh lighten your load
jason has referred to season two as your
empire strikes back
so how do you why do you feel that's a
good description of season two
what do you think that says about season
two
oh i shouldn't tell you this but uh i'm
just i'm just gonna do it uh beard gets
his hand cut off
ah rupert brings a sword and it cuts off
beard's hand
oh it just gets real dark it gets real
dark and then we have all these you know
talking dogs
uh you know that fight with rocks
oh you got it out of me you got it out
of me
sneaky christina it's a whole new world
in season two called endor i'll be
enough
yeah oh wait that's return of the jedi
oh my god i mixed my my star wars movies
oh no oh no the internet's going to come
for me
does it feel like it's darker at all
this season i mean
i don't know with the first three
episodes it still feels like
the a similar tone to season one so
i mean do we have more things in the
store that i'm not expecting
i mean i think so but i mean it's darker
maybe than a than a sitcom is supposed
to be um
but the thing is like it's really cool
that people look at the show
um and come away with this feeling of
positivity and
a degree of inspiration but even in
season one
season one is not all sunshine and roses
you know it's it's not the teletubbies
like
people we end up at a place of
positivity
after people go through some [ __ ] um
and because it's about it's about where
you are after you've gone through that
as opposed to just not going through
anything
so the microcosm of that is people will
continue to go through stuff
um in in season two and you see some of
that in the first few episodes but
there's a little bit more to come
jason has also talked about having a
very clear three season arc for the show
so if that is ultimately the case and
you only have one more season left to do
has that reality set in that saying
goodbye to these characters
is coming a lot sooner than you would
think
um we're just not there yet
you know like uh we're still we're still
in post on
on season two um so we cannot think that
that far ahead really
but you know one weird sort of sideways
way i thought about it was
uh you know
rap parties after a season are usually
you know
really raucous like we finished the
school year kind of events
um but our wrap party after season two
was less raucous i mean for two reasons
one you know it was covid
and uh we're outside there's no dj um
you know we're not we're not going nuts
but i realize later the other reason is
we know we're we know we're coming back
already
most shows don't typically know that so
there was not this sort of
extra gravity of uh of of goodbye will
we ever see each other again
we know we will but having said that
at the end of season three people are
gonna cry oh that wrap party is gonna be
a river of tears
um but also a dj so maybe that'll
balance out
do you know how this series is meant to
end i mean obviously don't
tell me because then they'd have to kill
me but do you know
where it's headed to essentially yes i
mean we know
we know the arcs of basically all the
characters
um you know once we get into the nuts
and bolts of putting that season
together
maybe the things we currently foresee
will change but
um as of now it's just a matter of like
how do we you know thread it all
together and make our
sort of you know narrative lattice uh
of everything we picture but basically
uh yeah
how does coach beard feel about lead
tasso and what was it like to actually
see that
brought to life i mean it was great to
see
because it you know harkens back to the
first commercials we did when it was a
different version of ted
not the gentler version that we sort of
started to discover in the second
commercials
um but in terms of beer's response
i mean it's just you know lead tassels
what you turn to when there's nothing
else and so
if we're gonna go to lead test though
that means we're in trouble already um
and of course there's the great fear
that such a powerful weapon can do more
damage than uh
than you want it to do so um
yeah it's it's a grave grave time
whenever uh
the dark aviator shades have to come out
so i'm feeling that
empire strikes back live then so it you
know
to circle back to that exactly see it
just creeps in all these little places
well as much as i love these characters
and each of the players
on this team they are a bit
dysfunctional so i was delighted by the
addition of the doctor who's
now there to help them what do you think
that adds to season two and and what do
you enjoy about what sarah niles brings
to the show
uh i mean cernell's a rock she's she's
just great
you know um and she's actually quite you
know quite a hoot
uh um uh
you know damn near bubbly but uh in
terms of the in the show
you know she's kind of a she's almost a
similar foil to roy
in a w in a way uh as roy was in season
you know the beginning of season one
but whereas uh roy was just
you know a mirror of anger in a weird
way maybe maybe a you know funny house
mirror of anger
uh um is even more of a blank slate you
know sharon is is more
you know mount rushmore or or easter
island uh rapa nui pardon me
um and she's also
you know actively studying ted while
she's giving him nothing
and so it's just a different different
dynamic for
uh you know another another hill for uh
ted to climb
and uh and i think it's fun and just i'm
just so happy we got sarah she's she's
fantastic
she did a great job this season and i'm
looking forward to everyone getting a
chance to check it out
well i'm i'm looking forward to seeing
more of her and more episodes
and thank you so much for talking to me
about the show
oh it's a pleasure thank you christina
cheers